trudeau justin trudeau um that i just
shake my head at that okay
oh man who capitalized without virtue on
the name of his father Wow yes Wow is
right he had an ounce of character he
would have never run I'm not happy about
him on he had no right well he had a
right he's a citizen he can run he
didn't earn his name not impressed
why do you say there's a specific
because his father was very famous sure
and so that put Trudeau at a tremendous
advantage with regards to moving into a
leadership position in Canada it's not
excusable you should move ahead on your
own merits especially if you're daring
to do something like run a country it's
like it's to you you have a moral duty
if you have the advantage of a name you
have a moral duty to supersede the
accomplishments of the person who bore
that name and gave it its weight before
you dare capitalize on it in the public
sphere and there's an Trudeau did none
of that he can he knows how to behave he
knows how to act in public he had the
upbringing for it other than that
there's nothing there not that I can see
and if there was he wouldn't have run
the way he did he's not not an
impressive person in my estimation some
strong opinions there's there when he he
appointed fifty percent of females to
fifty percent of his cabinet because it
was what he says well because it's 2015
it's like no quarter of your elected
members of parliament were female if you
would your job was to pick the most
qualified people period regardless of
their genitalia because they're leading
the country you pick the most qualified
people
steady abdicated his responsibility to
make those difficult decisions and then
wallpapered it over with a this casual
virtue of well I'm going to promote
women it's like no you're going to
promote competent people you weasel no
excuse for it Wow